quatre mois se sont écoulés depuis que
la russie a lancé les premières bombes
sur l'ukraine il ya eu les condamnations
puis une avalanche de sanctions mais la
vie en apparence ne pas vraiment changé
à moi
même le maître donald a rouvert les
russes ont racheté tous les restaurants
et les exploitent désormais sous le nom
de délicieux point c'est tout un
pied-de-nez à l'occident qui malgré tout
ne pas réussi à étouffer l'économie
russe et tant bien que mal la vie ici
continue la guerre qu'on soit pour ou
contre se discute loin des caméras
censure oblige
tout ira bien nous dit celui qui monte
la garde du matin au soir devant
l'immeuble où le bureau de radio canada
a pignon sur rue depuis
1978 est à moscou c'est ici sur la rue
dalhousie nce kika presse étrangère
s'était installé à l'époque et radio
canada n'est jamais parti
[Musique]
fidèle au poste
irina mednikova notre doyenne est
administratrice aura été là jusqu'à la
fin
pour le fly com
-
budget se
si le kremlin qui a ordonné la fermeture
de notre bureau à titre de représailles
contre le gouvernement canadien et nous
n'y pouvons strictement rien il faut se
résigner nous avons seulement quelques
jours pour vider le bureau de ses
souvenirs et surtout quitter nos
collègues calcul à elena dabach était
notre recherche ester interprète le
dictionnaire des expressions soviétique
way we trésor
avec ça
une bonne vivante est une encyclopédie
toujours au fait du moindre détail sur
l'histoire de son pays du papier kaas et
le point tranquillement au lieu de tout
jeter on a trouvé preneur chez ces
jeunes avocats ils ont aussi pris nos
meubles pour leurs nouvelles pratiques
qui se consacre à la défense des droits
de la personne et de la communauté lgbt
d'expérience olga cui est une juriste
elle ne connaissait pas radio canada
mais comprend très bien ce qui est en
jeu
le pays se referme
mais ces jeunes brave la tempête alors
que tant d'autres ont quitté la russie
ça fait du bien de les voir récupérer
notre décor quoique modeste il a bien
servi donc c'est comme une seconde vie
puis au moins on sait qu'on jette passe
à la poubelle puis que ça
ça va servir à des jeunes qui nous
expliquent qu'ils qui sentent le besoin
de rester en russie qu'il ya beaucoup
beaucoup d'eau angie qui sont partis
avec
alex est dit que 60% son entourage des
activistes et des militants ont plié
bagages
faire le ménage c'est aussi revivre
l'histoire du pays en accéléré certains
chapitres traînent encore dans un coin
du bureau sur ces vieilles qu'assad
eltsine sur l'amnestie l'ukraine bordel
économique
saas et
résultat des élections
tout ce n'était pas encore dans le
paysage
c'est une autre époque complètement
c'est les années de la chute de l'union
soviétique
cette transition et ses douloureuses car
russe sur quatre c'est céline galipeau
qui étaient ici dans les années 90 pour
apporter les premiers balbutiements
d'une russie démocratique
et journaliste michel cormier aura quant
à lui assisté au début de l'ère de
vladimir poutine l'un des obstacles
majeurs
caméraman à l'excellent give dont la
lentille à capter et documenter la suite
les soldats russes bloque toujours là au
près avec alexandra shatskoff jean
françois bélanger
ils ont témoigné des ambitions d'un
régime de plus en plus belliqueux les
autorités avec le journaliste raymond
saint-pierre il a vu son propre pays se
refermer à nouveau et ces dernières
années ont été marquées par la
répression de ceux qui osaient encore
tenir tête aux régions
cette photo avec l'opposant vladimir car
à mozac a été prise il ya moins d'un an
moscou il est désormais en prison pour
avoir critiqué l'opération militaire du
président
cette carte nous aura guidé jusqu'à la
toute dernière minute jusqu'à ce que la
guerre éclate aux frontières de l'ue
craint ça c'est la réussite telle quelle
mais vladimir poutine s'est aussi
vu l'état les verts vers l'ouest
et qui sait ce que l'avenir réserve
[Musique]
anastasia elle était la plus jeune de
notre équipe incarne cette génération
toujours optimiste même dans les moments
les cuissons
radio canada au fil du temps aura été là
pour les eaux et pour les bat
on va la garder la plaque c'est plus de
trente ans d'histoire grâce au canada en
russie dans les choses sont arrivés vite
ou dans les sphères consorts est appelé
pour le lui mais ça s'envole dans les
bagages
on espère que ce n'est qu'un au revoir
ici tu as mal de courage au canada
amusant